Why Do Clocks Run Clockwise?
Pretty much everyone knows that if you’re
asked to pass something clockwise around a
table, you hand it to the person on your left
because that is the same direction that the
hands of a clock move.
But what you may not know is that this standard
direction is a function not only of timekeeping,
but the Earth’s rotation and the happy accident
that much of human civilization evolved in
the Northern Hemisphere.
If you could look directly at the North Pole
from space, it would appear to spin counterclockwise.
Given that spin, when a stick is placed in
the ground parallel to the Earth’s axis
in, say, Egypt, the shadow cast by the stick
as the Sun moves across the sky will move
in a clockwise direction (notably, a similarly
placed stick in Australia would cast a shadow
that moves counterclockwise).
As far back as when the ancient Egyptians
and Babylonians were fashioning their first
shadow clocks (~3,500 BC), the measurement
of time moved in a clockwise direction.
Even as more precise timekeeping methods came
about, sundials (which began in earnest around
1,500 BC) remained popular throughout the
middle ages and beyond, given their simplicity
of construction and relative reliability.
(In fact, early mechanical clocks were often
regularly calibrated
to nearby sundials.)
So, when mechanical clocks were introduced
in Europe in the 14th century, their inventors
were quite familiar with sundials and the
clockwise direction that their shadows moved
and marked time.
Accordingly, by the end of that century when
even cathedral clocks were sporting clock
faces, they were made in imitation of their
sundial forbears, which included hands that
moved in a clockwise direction.
Notably, the word clockwise with its present
meaning did not appear in English until the
1870s, with counterclockwise also dating to
that decade.
The use of wise to mean a way of proceeding
dates back to Old English.
Clock isn’t nearly so old, and dates to
the invention of our modern mechanical clocks
(14th century).
It is thought to come from either clokke (Middle
Dutch), cloque (Old North French) or clocca
(Medieval Latin) which all meant bell.
Some of the earliest mechanical clocks were
simply designed to strike a bell at set intervals,
perhaps to announce prayer times or the like,
or simply ring on the hour, with these early
clocks not necessarily having any faces.
And if you’re curious, before they were
called “clocks,” these early mechanical
clocks were called horologia, from the Greek
for “hour” (ὡρα) and “to tell”
(λέγειν).
Ever wonder what a.m. and p.m. stand for?
Well, wonder no more: a.m. stands for “ante
meridiem”, which is Latin for “Before
Midday”; p.m. stands for “Post Meridiem”,
which is Latin
for “After Midday”.